今日は66番からお願いします
では 英語で読みます Charanti
bala dummedha amitte neva attana. Karonta papakaṃ kamma
ṃ yaṃ hoti katukapphalaṃ.
Charanti bala dummedha amitte neva attana. Karonta papakaṃ
kammaṃ yaṃ hoti katukapphalaṃ.
えっと66番目の偈で
あの どういう意味でしょうかというと
このbalaね 愚か者っていうね
知恵のない人々は またdummedhaっていうのはまた同じ意味で
知恵がないって bala
っていうのは まあ劣っている人っていう意味で dummedha
っていうのは知恵がないという風になりますけど
厳密に まあ劣っていて
知恵のない人はamitte neva何か敵のごとくattanaっていうのは自分に対して
それから逆に言えば自分に対して敵のごとくcharanti生活する
だから知恵のない劣っている人々は
自分自身に対して敵であるかのように生活をすると Karonta
papakaṃ kammaṃ yaṃ hoti katukapphalaṃ.これどういうことかという説明ですけど Karonta
しながらっていう しているんだと papakaṃ
kammaṃ悪業 悪行為をするんだと yaṃ
hoti katukapphalaṃ
これはとても厳しい結果になるんだと katukai
っていうのは この耐え難い苦しみになる結果だから
耐え難い苦しみになる結果を生み出してくれる悪業をすることで
愚か者が自分に対して敵のごとく生きているんだと
すごく分かりやすいものですからね
はい で あの あまり説法するところはございませんので
まあ次の方だけしかないんですけど
知恵のない人の生き方っていうのは
まあ自分に対して敵のごとく生きているということであって
で これは人間の生き方
どのような生き方でしょうかと
人間では一般的に言えば知恵があるとはちょっと言いにくいでしょうし
何やっても我々はどこかでそれはねじったり曲げたりして
この結果出ないようにするという風にしちゃうんですね
あるいはもう自分好きなように物事は解説する
それで人っていうのは誰でもだいたいこの自分に対していいことだと思って
自分がやりたいんだからと思って
我々の好き嫌いで 好みで生活する
だいたい人間は自分で私はこのような人間だ
このように生きているんだというふうに厳しく定めておくんですね
で 違うことを聞いても
自分のセッティングしているシステムに合わせて強引に合わせるんですね
合わせると言ったっても
余計なこと全部切って自分の入れ物に入るようにする
そうすると本物ではなくなりますからね
絵画買ってきて 壁のところはすごい小さいんだから
そこでも切って捨てると壁に合わせてとかね
柱にかけたいんだから
柱の大きさに絵画を切ってしまって意味がないんですけど
しかし 我々の生き方っていうのは
そういうふうな生き方になっているんですね
それが正しいと大体人は思っているんですね
自分の生き方は正しいと
そういうわけで正しい生き方をしているんだと
もう人から何いちいち悪るい必要はないんだぞというふうに生き方しています
問題は そういう生き方は
本人が知恵があるならばね
知恵が完成しているならば
真理を知っている人であるならば
私はこのように生きていますよと決めてもいいんですけど
だから我々には それは自分の人生そうやって決めて決める資格があるんでしょうかとね
自分が人生の経験があるのかとかね
何か成り立たないんですね
人生経験があったら もうとっくに生活しているでしょうし
もう終わっているよ 人生はね
物事を知っているのか
世の中のことを知っているのか
真理真理は知っているのか
心の奥底知っているのかどうかね
そういうものっていうのは
本当によく知り尽くしている人であるならば
まあそれですから 私はこういうふうな生き方をするんだよと自分の生き方を決めればいいんです
しかし そういうもの何もないんだからこそ
私はこのように生きていますよとみんな決めてしまうんですね
だから別な言葉に入れ替えると
なんであなたは自分の生き方決めたんでしょうかって
だって私には何もわからないんだから
私はそういう 何て言いますか
人生のことを全然わからないんだから
人生はこうであるべきと決めつけましたよと
で 決めつける資格はないんだからこそ
私がやっていますよと
だから これはたとえればもう私に免許証がないんだから運転させてくれと
運転は習ったことは 習ったことは全然ないんだと
触ったこともないんだと
あのステアリングっていうやつをね
触ったことがない だからやらせてくれと
私はあなた方をちゃんと運んであげますよという話なんですよ
例えば外国語はさっぱり一言もわからないんですから
私はもう一流の通訳者として雇ってくださいと
通訳は私に頼んでください
なぜでしょうか 全然外国語はわからないんだからと
そう言われると話にならないでしょうし
そういう例えが本当におかしい
しかし 我々の生き方はどうでしょうかというと
我々はどのように生きるべきかとさっぱりわからないし
人生って何をさっぱりわからないし
どう生きるべきかということは勉強して学んだこともないし
真理はわからないし まず簡単に言えば真理がわからない人は
自分で自分の生き方を決めつけて
決めつけておくんですね
これは話にならないんですよ
だから外国語はさっぱりわからないんだから
通訳者として仕事をお願いしますという話でしょうし
だから小さい時から自分はっきりしなさいとかね
よく言われて だから小さい時は子供は別に何かやりたいという気持ちはあまりないんですよ
だから責めちゃうんですね
自分で何かやりたい やることをはっきり決めなさいとかね
早く決めなさいとかね
自分の将来でしょうと
自分で決めなくちゃいけないでしょうという風に
世の中で知識人たちや大人たちは子供たちに言うんですね
それで子供は何も知らないうちに何か決めなくちゃいけないんですね
私は将来こうなりますとかね
そこで資格は知らないことなんですね
知らないんだから決めましたという資格
だから運転できないんだから運転頼みましたという話なんですね
それから じゃああんたは運転免許持ってないでしょう
じゃあでしたらもう運転お願いしますといて運転してもらう
だから子供は自分の人生は小さい時
強引に責められたところで
じゃあ将来こうしますと決めたところで
それからはい 頑張ってくださいと
それでやらせるんですね
で うまくいくわけじゃないんですね
大体は だから世の中はうまくいってないんですよ
うまくいってないというのはあまり聞きたくないかもしれませんだけど
うまくいってるって言ってほしいしね
大体は 素晴らしいと この世界は
だから誰か誰かさんの真似をして
あの人のようになりなさい
この人のようにやりなさいと言ったりする
では 我々はあの人のようにやりなさい
この人 この人 この人をモデルにして生活しない
その人のことを知っているのかと
知らないでしょうに ただテレビで見たとか
新聞で読んだとか 本で読んでみましたとか
その程度のことです で
人のことを本で書いてあったっても
ほとんど作品で面白おかしく読んでもらいたいということで
いろいろ調整して調整して書くものだから
事実ということになりませんしね
ですから このあまりにも知らないにも関わらず
あの人のようになりたい
この人のようになりたいとかね
ある若者は私にずっと手紙を書いてあって
もう本人 初めの手紙からも気持ち悪くなっちゃって
もう支離滅裂書いてるものはね
で 本人がすごい理屈書いてるようなつもりなんですけど
自分がとにかく頑張って世界一の人間になりたいんだという話なんです
だから協力してくれと
世界一の科学者になりたいんだと
と言いながら何書いているのかというと
おいつは中学の成績がまずい
高校の成績は全くダメで
もう大学入学はダメ できん
あれすっごく腹が立ちましたけど
私には勉強できないんだから世界一科学者になりますという話でしょうに
それで私もお金払わなくちゃいけないんですね
援助しなくちゃいけないんです
あれだらしないやつらには援助したっても
もうただお金で遊ぶだけで終わっちゃうでしょうに
逆に言えば 私は言ってみたんですけど
いろいろ問題があって
仕事も勉強もうまくいかなかったと
ですから 商売でもやって何とか食べていきたいんだから
いくらかお金くれませんかと言ったら
それは理屈でしょうに
だから勉強するんだと言ったら
いくらもうずっと限りなくあげなくちゃあかんだからね
商売でもやりたいと言ったら
一回一回あげて それでダメだったらもう出て行けと言えるしね
そこら辺考えてるでしょうね
おそらく それでまたこの
アインシュタインはどうでしょうかとかね
アインシュタインも学校ではダメでしたでしょうとかね
これでやれやれと思ったんですね
アインシュタイン アインシュタインに対してとんでもない嘘をいんちき書いてあってね
世界中あちこち それはさらにさらにもう変えて
変えて変えて それで新聞記事なんかで
このツーコラム ワンコラムぐらいで
アインシュタインはこういう人だと書いてるものって
じゃあアインシュタインも学校で成績が悪かったんだから
俺もアインシュタインみたいな人間になるんだぞと
だからアインシュタインみたいアインシュタインみたいな人間になるための資格は学校の成績
成績が悪いことで そういう理屈なんですね
アインシュタインでも生まれ時からもう桁違い
知識人でしたし もう並大抵の人間ではなかったでしょうに
で それ書いちゃうとあまり面白くないんだから
学校で成績が悪くて先生に怒られましたと
書いた方は読む人の気分がいいでしょう
それでアインシュタインこういう風にものを発見すると
ざまあみろ 親頑張った
よくできたというね こんなこの怠け者のこの腰抜けの負け犬たちの気分を取るために文章を書くんですよ
アインシュタインはもう小さい時からもう桁違い天才でしたと言ったところで
やっぱりということになっちゃってね
俺がアインシュタインにはなりっこはないんだと
褒めなくてもいいんだと
なんでアインシュタインのことをすごく褒めてるんでしょうか？と
ああいう自伝のせいなんです
我々にも明るい 明るい光をさせてくれているんだと
何考えてるんですかね
それでアメリカでこの発明の旦那が勘だらけの人がいるでしょ
誰でしたっけ あ エジソンとかね
まあ先生はもうお母さんに頼んだと
もう学校に送らないでくださいと
それぐらい出来が悪かったと
それで発明の王様のように
それでやっぱり自分にも希望がありそうで
冗談じゃないんですよ
エジソンというのはまだ小さい時からもうすごい人で
学校で何言われても お母さんがビシビシと教えてるんでしょ
家で それで もう別に学校に行かなくたって
あいつはもうほとんど全部お勉強しているんです
だからどうせ男だから
学校でふざけたり いろんなことやったりして
もういい加減なことをやったりして
それで先生はもう もうこれはちょっと頭が痛いんだと
学校に出さないでくれと
お母さんから見ても やっぱりこいつはもう悪ガキでね
みんなに迷惑かけるんだから
いいやと学校に行かなかった
問題ないんだからね それで本人がいろんなものを開発する気持ちじゃなくて
もうそれなりにすごい真剣に真面目に頑張って
そういう結果になったんであって
こんな負け犬たちに希望の星じゃないんですよ
結局は誰一人も それだったら因果法則に逆らっているでしょうに
物事は因果法則でしょうに
肥料をあげなくても ものすごくもうもういっぱい実っているんだそうとか
何考えているんですかね
石の上で種をまいたっても
もう大きいもう木に成長しましたよとか
それってのはありえないことで
立派な木に成長したければ
立派な土地に植えて 立派に面倒見てあげて
水をあげて肥料をあげて育てなくちゃいけないでしょうに
それで初めから知ってるじゃん
この土地は素晴らしいし
環境は素晴らしいし 土の土の質もよろしいし
そこで種種もすごいいい
いい種であるし そういう植えた人もちゃんと知っている人であって
面倒見ているんだと それだったら元気な木になるんだぞっていうことは当たり前の話でしょうに
だから因果法則っていうのはあまりにも当たり前だからつまらないんですね
だから因果法則と逆らった話が随分人気あるんです
だからハリーポッターの本のシリーズと同じなんですよ
無茶人気あるんです わざとその人がもうあり得ないということを徹底的に書くんです
ありえないことが常識で
もう常識なことは全然おかしいんだと
だから私はあの本はすごく面白い
これってすごい面白いんだとみんな馬鹿にしているんだと
みんな馬鹿にされちゃって
みんなお金払って本買うんだから
だからあの本では この何て言いますか
魔法使いでないことがおかしい
魔法の力であれこれと何でもかんでもやらない
おかしいでしょう ということで
だからまあその人はやっぱり人間が何知りたがっているのかと
何も知りたがって知りたがらないんですね
本当は だからありえないことを書いてくれと
特にどんなドラマでもね
普通の常識の耳で 目で見たり聞いたりすると
もうおかしくて腹が立つんですよ
馬鹿にするんじゃないんだ
でもその目じゃなくてぼけーと見ていると面白いとかね
感動的だと涙まで流しちゃうんだから
今日朝は何かチャンネルがテレビで試験的な放送がありまして
また新しいチャンネル
いくつかもう 作ろうと思っている人おりますけどね
これで前一回見たことがある映画を流していたんですね
で 丁度の最後のところでしたけど
ただぼけーと見ていたんですね
ある一箇所で この最初のセクションで
かなり遠い誰も知らないところにこの人が行かなくちゃいけないんですね
主役が それでまた外国で
行って そこら辺は人から道を聞いて
聞いて聞いて聞いて で
すごい距離 山 ヒッチハイクで行く
いろいろとヒッチハイクでも山ででっかい木なんか伐採して
それを運んでくるトラックなんかに手を出して
なんとかそうやってもやっとそのところに行ったんですね
行ったらこのもうボロけたお城でね
そこまでいいんだけど
そのお城の横にまた車が止まってるんですね
何だこれと私は考えるんですよ
なぜかというと 次の場面にその人はその車に乗って帰らなくちゃいけないんです
だから最初から用意しているという
ストーリー成り立ちませんだけどね
私たちにとっては まあ因果法則だったら面白くないんですね
百姓さんが汗流して畑を耕して
毎日のように面倒を見て
それなりに収穫はありましたと
それはストーリーになりません
百姓さんが苦労して畑を耕したところで
なんて見事なことに そこら辺ですごい台風が来て
洪水があって 周りの畑が全部壊れてしまったと
流されしまったと それで大金持ちが来て
この人の作物を全部買って
この人はもうもう 1日にしてもうすごい金持ちになりましたと
ああ これは面白い話ですね
だいたいそういうふうな話が好きということが
我々はそんなような人間ということなの
因果法則はもう面白くない
奇跡の話 驚く話  なんて
なんとか日本の言葉ありますね
この一角  一攫千金  一攫千金の話
でなきゃダメなんです
だから結局は私たちの個人の生き方の哲学もそういうふうになっているんです
だからダメになるっていうのは決まってるんです
で そういう考え方っていうのは
まあ愚か者っていうことになるんですよ
そのうちよくなるんだよと
そのうちよくなるわけじゃないでしょ
よくなりたければ すごい具体的に考えて行動しなくちゃいけないんですよ
それがやりたくないんですね
地道に 具体的に 論理的に
物事をやりたくはないんです
それで夢を作る 期待希望を作る
期待も希望もないあなたの人生って何なのかと批判までする
下らん期待希望ない人はすごい現実主義者でしょうに
現実主義は面白くないんですね
学校で勉強できないんだから
ノーベル賞取れるぐらいの科学者になるんだぞと思った方が素晴らしいんですね
活発な若者で  [笑い]みんなで応援してやるやりましょうと
私にもずっと手紙が来る
あの人の手紙 1枚も書いたことはないんで
返事として 書きたくは
書いちゃうともう本当のことを書きますからね
だから結局はもう怒りと欲と憎しみやら
そういうもう感情ばっかしで
まあ子供にしてもいろいろ憧れちゃうとかね
テレビのあの画面見て誰か誰かに憧れちゃうと
あれってもう明らかにもうインチキもいいところでしょうに
もうたまたま行って見学に行ってみたらどうでしょうかと
そういうスタジオなんか
そういうところはどういうところかと
天国のようにカメラに映りますけど
もうゴミ捨て場より気持ち悪いところなんですよ
ものすごい汚いし ホコリだらけで
それでテレビで映るあのセクションだけは
まあ天国のように それに憧れるとかね
どういうことかと だからいろんなことに憧れしたっても
我々はただ上辺だけ見て憧れたってもね
まあそれで成り立たないんですよ
何かを得るっていうことは地道な行為の結果であって
因果法則はもう否定できないでしょうし
因果法則を無視してどうにもならんでしょうね
運転頼む頼むならば ちゃんと運転免許を取っていて
無事故なしね 無事故で運転した経験ある人に頼むんであって
腕がいい人に頼むんであって
そうするといい結果が出るでしょうに
まあだからこの餅という機能はね
かなり厳しく 人間生命の人生に働きかけていて
それでどうなるのかで自分がやりますけど
自分のためだと思って
本当はそれは自分に対して敵のごとくやっていることなんです
だから 寝たいんだから寝るならば
喋りたいんだから喋っているならば
遊びたいんだから遊んでいるならば
怒りたいんだから怒っているならば
もう自分の敵なんですよ
だから やりたいことをやって生きるべきかといえば
これ逆なんです やりたいことって全部やめた方がいいんです
何か本格的にやりたいと調べてみればとんでもないことなんですよ
人々に聞いて 自分自身で聞いてみたら
自分がやりたくないものは何なのか
リストを作ってみれば
必ずやらなくちゃいけないことのリストになるんです
あなたがやりたいことのリストを書いてくださいっちゃうと
もうやったらもう地獄に落ちるリストになっちゃうんです
なのにとにかくもう頑張って苦労してでもやりたいことをやろうとするんです
例えば年取ってエベレストに登った人って
その人はやりたいんだからやったんではなく
違いますよ やりたいやりたくないじゃなくて
あれはすごい挑戦だから
私はもう世界で一番年長老でもうエベレストを制覇するんだぞとか
世界記録を出してやる
そんな気持ちではうまくいかないんでは全くいかないんですよ
まずできっこはないってことははっきりあって
もういくらでも途中でやめることになるんだぞってのがあって
それからすごいお金もかかってかかるんであって
これ色々プロジェクトを立てなくちゃいけないし
とにかくできないことを大変なことばっかり連続してやって
それを一つ一つ乗り越えていくことで
その人はこの無理に挑戦するんでしょうに
やりたいことをやっているんじゃないんです
無理ということに挑戦していくんですよ
そこで頂上にのってしまうんですね
だからどちらにしてもきっちり
例えばエベレストに乗った人の場合でも
もし現実主義者でなかったらどうなるんですかね
その時ももうあまりにも雪がひどくて
天気が悪くて もうもう死にそうになったところで
そこで光が現れてきて導かれましたとか
どうせ山はもう我は我は日本人だから山を信仰してるんだから
山の神様に守ってくれてるんだから
じゃあ登るぞとか 山の神信じちゃったら登りくはないでしょう
死にます 自分の足を信じているんです
と技術とテクノロジーを
その場合はすごく因果法則
現実主義でしょうに だからその人でも
もうただ歳ということで
もうちやほやするんであって
それで老人たちに まあもう希望の星が輝いているんだと
冗談じゃないんですよ
他の人の登ろうとしたらもう死にますからね
よくよく見ると その人はもう登山家で
もうだからずっと鍛えている体だから
もう歳といってもね もう普通の若者と同じ筋肉力持ってますしでしょうし
それにちょっと面白くないんですよ
だから彼の身体検査結果は絶対出しませんね
彼が体力テスト受けちゃうと
の人には必ず勝ちますよ
それは言わない方がいいんです
それはカット 歳 世界一
というふうにストーリー作るんですね
だから一般人というのはどういうことは他というとね
だからその人の金を騙し取らなくちゃいけないんだから
この問題は解決しませんよ
ニュース書く時でも 文章書く時でも
そういうバカを騙して金取るためにやってるんです
新聞 雑誌 記事 なんだらかんだら全て
品物を開発したっても
いかにバカを騙して金を取ろうかという
そういうことで お釈迦様がおっしゃっているのは
この人間っていうのはやっぱりすごく
まあ先わからない 何が善か何が悪かわからない
なのに自分で判断して
私の人生の設計は私がするんだよと思って人生設計してやってますけど
それが自分を敵に回していることであると
だから自分が敵になるっていうことは
素晴らしい言葉で単語であっても
どうしようもないってことなんです
敵が外から来るならば攻撃態勢があるんですね
敵の表れ具合を見ながら
こちらもう防衛態勢を取ればいいでしょうに
自分が敵だったらどうするんでしょうかね
これ大変な問題 だから自分が何やろうとしたっても
自分自身が敵だから それが自分の敵の行為でしょうに
危ないんですよ 大胆な敵で
あんまり仏教を学んでることで仏法僧冒涜して地獄に落ちる可能性もあります
そうすると 仏教に興味を持った人々は天国に行っちゃって
一生懸命やった人は地獄にいるっていうはめに
もうなりかねませんよ
ちゃんと智慧がないと
あまりにも自分の主観で
これはこうだあれはああだとか判断したりしちゃうと
そういうのはできないはずなんです
しかし 最初からもうこうであるべきか
あるべきだと決めつけてから
何学んだってもあんまり役に立ちませんね
こうであるべきだ 私はこういうものを探していたんだとかね
これではね だから智慧の人のやり方っていうのは
すごい具体的で現実的で
お釈迦様が涅槃を探し求めたんじゃないんですよ
解脱を探し求めたんじゃないんです
悟りを探し求めたでもないんです
明確に書いてますけど
お釈迦様 この限りのない苦しみから
苦しみがなんとかならないのかと
すごい具体的なんです
生きることは限りのない苦であると
これまたいくらやっても
いくらやっても いくら生きてみたっても
生きること自体が苦であると終わりがないんだと
これがなんとかならないのかという
何にもならないというところなんですね
生きることは苦であるならば
何か解決する方法を見つけたと
まだ生きているんだから
苦うでしょうに 生きること
じゃあ死んでしまえば？死んでしまったってももう終わらないんだから
そういうことで無理に挑戦する
それまたものすごく具体的で
着々と 乗り越えるべき障害をはっきりと出会う
障害にしっかりと出会って
それを乗り越える 次の障害にぎしんと出会って
それを乗り越えると 生きる苦しみっていうのは具体的に現実的にありますからね
その原因もしっかりとあるんだからね
それに立ち向かって乗り越えて乗り越えていく
こういう境地に行くぞっていうことはないんです
涅槃という境地に達するぞとか
分かってるんですかね
そんなのは 苦しんでる人は
世間の考え方 いつでも明るい未来を設定して
それを目指して頑張るんです
それ自体が自分を敵に回すことなんです
よくも鈍足に苦しんで鈍足な無知な人なのに
明るい未来の設計図を書くこと？だから完全に資格がない
だからこそその仕事をやりたくなるという
それだったら自分の敵は自分でしょうに
運転できないんだから
私は運転すると言ったら
じゃあ一人で運転してみなさいと言ったら
まあ二 三秒でしょ 運転してみたっても
人生は 二 三秒で事故なんです
だからそれで運転できない人は運転して車をどこかもうあまり遠く行けませんから
そこら辺誰かにぶつけ
当たってね 人にも怪我して
自分も怪我したって もうもう重体になったというのは誰のせいですかね
自分が自分にやったことです
でも やりたいことをやってよかったねと
言わなくちゃいけないんです
やりたいことをできてよかったという人生じゃないんですよ
人生っていうのは複雑です
よくリスト作ってみると
やっぱりやりたくないものは自分のためになるものであって
やりたいものっていうのは結局は自分のためになるリストになる
それで人格を向上する人は
やっぱりこの具体的に問題にぶつかってみて
そこはなんとかならないのかと
世界一になってやるぞという考え方はないんです
目の前にある問題を解決するんです
だから競争的なもう選択
厳しい選択試験が 自分のこの場合は全国試験だからね
かなり競争厳しいんです
夢はどうでもいいでしょうに
もう世界一の科学者になりたいとかね
まあそんなことはどうでも
自分の今抱えている問題はどうでしょうかと
自分が抱えているこの試験という問題は
解読 解き 乗り越えることできないんだったらね
もう現実主義者じゃないでしょう
足元を見ないで遠くを見る
こけちゃいますから 足元のそこと先
すごい崖があると 遠く見ているんだから
遠くの美しいもう場所を見ているんだから
美しい庭園を見ているんですね
そこ目て走り出すとこっちは崖なんですよ
それで死んじゃうんです
で まあそういうことなので
まあ現実的で因果法則に基づいてものをことを考えなくちゃいけないんです
なりたい気持ちではなくて
今置かれている状況はどう脱線するのかと考えた方がいいんです
[背景音楽]でお釈迦様がおっしゃりたがるのは
やっぱりこの人間っていうのは盗みやってる時でも喜んでやっていて
嘘を言う時でも喜んでやっていて
人を騙す時でもすごく喜んでやっていて
よこしまない行為をするということすごく喜んでやっていて
もうやりたくてたまらないという
うまくいったら自慢までする
結局は因果法則からは脱出できません
すべて因果法則だから
そこから出て行ったということはありえないんです
だから 行為の結果からは逃げられません
行為は自分がするんだから
自分の敵は自分でやるということになるんです
一番恐ろしい問題です
敵は外にいないということ
それで他宗教と比較すると
これが明確に違うポイントなんですね
罪は外の何かの原因で現れたんだってっていう話と
いえ 自分自身だと 自分の敵は自分でやるということを考えちゃうと
もう大変ですよ だから誰かさんに救ってもらおうかなと思ったら
考えたのは誰ですかね
自分でしょ やらない方がいいんです
自分が敵だからね だから自己と戦うことしか答えがないんですよ
自己を潰すしか答えじゃないんですよ
だから自我のないという話になるんです
自分で考えた救いの道は確実に解脱じゃなくて地獄の道になっちゃうんです
考えられるはずがないんです
自分という気持ち自体が危ないんです
そんなところだと思いますけどね
まあこの経典でこの言葉に言ってることは
で 悪いことをする場合は面白い現象なんですけど
面白いんですね それが
悪いことならもうすごい面白いんです
それを覚えておかないと
他のところでお釈迦様おっしゃってますからね
つのごとく美味しいんだと
悪いことは それやってる時は
だからやめられないんですよ
しかし結果は次に出ますからね
悪い行為自体も苦しくて
あるいは苦しいであるならば悪いことしませんよ
悪いことが苦しくないんです
楽なんです 俗世間でも苦しみに耐えた人は成功者でしょう
苦しみに厳しさに負けた人は負け犬でしょう
俗世間でも同じこと 苦労は我慢できんだったら
じゃあもう堕落しなさいと
堕落の道は苦しくないんです
そういうこと決まりだからしょうがないんですね
悪はもう本当に面白い
善行為は全然面白くない
そういうふうになってますから
俺自分の気持ちな感情なんですよ
だから感情で生きてるんだから
適当的な生き方になってしまうんですよ
もう自我を潰すしか道がないんです
具体的 合理的 論理的な答えは
自我意識を潰すことなんです
それでお釈迦様は自我意識潰してみたところで
やっと幸福になりますと
[音楽]それで私たちはなんで頑張ってるようなことというと
自我を肯定するために確立するためなんですよ
自分を 自分のアイデンティティを作るためなんですね
逆なんです 瞑想してて私は覚者だよと
悟った人だよと言いたくて
もう もしかすると名刺にそれも入れたくてね
田中一郎小覚者とかね
これでは道がもう逆ですよ
自我でやるともうたとえ瞑想でも結局は逆の後ろ向いて走ってるだけ
そういう まあだからこの自我意識自体自体が問題であって
自分で判断する判断してやってますからね
それでまあ何とかしてその問題を解決すると
自我という問題を解決すると
だから自我を確立確定するんじゃないんです
エゴを確立確定するんじゃないんです
それ潰すんです その気持ちをね
別にエゴってあるわけじゃないし
初めから 自我が初めからあるものでもないし
だからもうどうったことはないんですけど
愚か者の生き方はそちらの反対になってますよと
これは大変な重大な ものすごい高度な問題なんです
お経の言葉を見てみれば
シンプルでなんだこれやっていうことかもしれませんだけど
実際はこれはもう生命の心の働きにある根本的な問題なんです
そこをわかってない人々は
他外に他に救いを求めたりする
救いを求めても自我がそのままだからね
その求める救いが救いではないんです
地獄に落ちることになっちゃうんです
ですから 世の中 人間がどんなものを考えてやっても
結局は結果は矛盾的になるんです
問題が起きるといろいろ解決策を練るでしょう
練っても練っても やっぱりそこで悪い
何て言いますか 短所が確実にあるんです
自我で考えてるんだからね
[背景音楽]だから全体的に世の中はいい方向へ進んでいるわけじゃないんです
しかし 自我に基づいていい方向へ持っていこうという努力はあるんです
だからいろいろ変化はあるんだけど
プラスマイナスで見ると進んでないんです
もう毎日毎日何か新しいものをやりましょうと
いうことでかなり頑張ってはいるんですよ
しかし 何か新しいものを作っちゃうと
それに関連して悪結果がサーッと出てくるんです
それで 例えばね 医学の世界でこの臓器移植技術を開発しちゃって
ああ良かったと思いきや
何か他のところで問題が起きたりする
それで この移植 臓器移植の場合はそのまま移植しなくちゃいけないんだけど
今の医療ではいろんな体の部品を保管しておいて
人々に体に入れたりする
それはもう死体から骨やら皮膚やら
もう細胞組織いろいろ取って
そこはまたいろいろ処理して
もう商品として作って置いておくんです
で それぞれ病気の人々にそれをもう何のことなくあげたりする
それでこの間読んだ記事なんですけど
遺体盗むっていうことになっちゃった
で 体を部品をね そうやって工場に送っていろいろ作るならば
それは親戚が提供しなくちゃいけないし
それで病気の病気かかっているならば取らないし
それでこの葬儀屋さんに遺体を運んだら
ずいぶん喜んでやってきて
もうずいぶん値段も安く全部やってあげますよと言ったら
この調べたらこの腰の下
もう腰の下から何もないんだって
後でこの問題が起きちゃって
このもう掘ってみたりしたところで
で 足の先っぽ切って このあれPVCパイプありますね
それで体の中にこれ曲げて入れて
これネジで足の裏からネジネジで足をPVCパイプにつなげて
それで覆うてもう体全体的にあるように見せかけちゃって
半分が全部取っているんです
骨を全部骨と もう臓器というか組織ですね
遺体まで盗むと なぜならば
この体のボディ ボディパーツと言うんですけど
このボディパーツをいろいろ再生して
そのそのいろいろ病気ある人々に治療するために使えるんだという技術が開発したんですよ
それがいいセクションで病気の人は助かりますから
同時にこれで遺体泥棒が出てくる
そうなってくると 法律でものすごい厳しく裁かなくちゃいけなくなっちゃう
それで遺体をあげたくても
ものすごく検査 検査 検査で
で また品物がなくなっちゃうんですね
この薬品作る工場に 遺体は来ないんだから
そういうことで 一つ開発して
万々歳かというと いつでもそうじゃなくて
確実に裏で何かというね
例えば遺伝子 このクローン技術ですか
これからしたらやってみたがるんですね
クローンしたらどうでしょうか
そこで欲は絡んでますけど
まあ完璧な牛だったら
もうそれでクローンした方が早いんじゃないかとかね
いっぱい牛を作って食えるんだと
品質管理はもうぎっしりできるんだと
で そのためには もうまず本当にそれできるかないかっていうことをね
いろいろ実験してみなくちゃいけないんですね
それは実験する以前にもう法律でやめるはめになっちゃったんですね
なんで科学者のことにそんなに法律で危ないと口を出すんですかということを
科学者もろくな人間じゃないっていうことでしょう
研究する前に禁止命令が来るんだから
もし科学者は人類のために人類の幸福ということを純粋に思っているならば
禁止命令出してはいけませんよ
たとえたまたま失敗があっても
たまたま悪い結果が出たっても
その人々はもうとにかくもう失敗しつつもいいことを作るんだから
もう自由にやらせた方がいいんだけど
クローン技術はやる前に禁止っていうことになっちゃう
それはやる前に禁止になったのは
まあ西洋人はね まあすごい理性的な人間だから
神様はちゃんといると信じているんだからね
で これは神様の領域管轄を
まあであるとよくわかってるみたいですね
科学研究はすべて神様の領域を侵略することになりますけどね
自分の都合によって考えちゃうんです
だからクローン技術が一般的になったら
人間何するかとまたわからなくなっちゃうでしょうし
というわけで この自我でやってることだから
頑張っても頑張ってもそんなもんだと
インターネットを普及したことで良かったではなくて
すごい問題ばっかり起きたっていうことでしょう
まず犯罪に使うという
とても簡単に国際的に連絡をできると
そこで私たちの個人自由さえ今なくなってますから
人のデータ盗まれるわ
コンピューターに強引にアクセスするわ
結局は人の家に勝手に空き巣に入るような感じでしょ
だから外へ出る時間がないんだから
私も何か買いたいものがあったらいつでもインターネットで注文したりはするんだけど
いつダメになるかわからないんですよ
だってカード番号送らないと
途中で取ったらどうするのかと
途中で取らなくても 店は日本だったらとっても危険なんです
アメリカから買う場合は一回きりでも次は知らん
その人々は私のことは
また注文すると また最初からももう
カード番号とか入れなくちゃいけない
それを取り消すんですよ
日本では一回買ったらそれで終わり
次に何か買いたければ
それも買いますと言ったら
もうはい ありがとうございますとボタン一回で
で 一週間 二週間経つともう品物は来ているっていうことになっているんです
ということは 個人データが全部自分で会社の採算として取っているって
こちら許可出してないんだけど
なんで本一冊買っただけでね
私の生年月日から何から何までそちら記録しておかなくちゃあかんですかね
まあそれもしょうがないと
会社から盗めるでしょう
データは その会社で仕事している人は
その腹が立って会社辞める場合はあの推理を持っていきますから
だから結局自分の銀行のお金でも
もう誰でも好き勝手に取れる世界になってしまったんです
だから一つ開発すると
そちらでまたもっと大きな問題が起こるんですね
で なんでそうなるんですかね
こんなに立派な人間 こんなに頭が良くて
恐ろしいほど物知り屋でしょ
技術者 科学者ももう信じられない
この知識のレベルは しかし
ろくに何一つもできない
だからこの昔から今まで社会は発展しているとかね
進歩しているんだと 人間の能力は見る見るうちに向上しているとか
そんなのは迂闊に言えたものじゃないんです
もう確実にみんな頑張ってるんだから
いろいろ変化を毎日はある
あるんだけど 新しいものを何か開発すると
そちらの図鑑も必ず付いているんですね
図形副作用なし 何も現れませんね
よきよく考えると 副作用の方がこの図形の方が一番危なくて
これは自我の問題な自我で考えることだから
まあどうでもいいと 私はこういうことをしようと考えましたよと
あんたどうでもどうでもいいやと
私ならどうでもいいやと言うんですよ
そんなすごいことを考えたってもいいし
考えなくてもどうでもいい
どうってことないんだと
でも相手がすごく素晴らしいですね
あなた本当にいい考え方と褒めてほしいんだけどね
褒められませんね 仏教の立場から
自我で考えるのは いくら素晴らしいもので見えても
確実にそこで落とし穴もある
それがないがしろにして何か考えるということはできません
だからこの 自我を貫くということが最終的な解決方法になるんです
それには異論は成り立ちません
自我のある人はいくらでも異論を作りますけど
それは異論にはなりません
このある人のエピソードがございまして
お釈迦様の時代で 何か
すっごい貧乏な人がいたんです
で ものすごい貧乏で この人はこの生まれつき障害者でというか
この身体的にはもう体曲がっているんですね
ぐにゃぐにゃに曲がっていて
背がこうやって伸ばすことはできないと
だから まあ本当はまあ醜い体というよりは醜い体で
その上まあどうしてもね
その人に仕事はくれないわ
もうもう難しいんだから
生活はね すごく貧しいんですね
そういう人であっても
お釈迦様のところには行ける
お釈迦様のところだけはね
まあ偉い人も偉くない人も誰でも入られる
その人はお釈迦様が説法しているところに行って
まあ貧しい人だからどこかにもうまた体もおかしいしね
障害者でもあるし 一応ずっと話を聞いていたんですね
話を聞いてると この人は真理を発見しちゃったんです
で 喜びに悟ってしまったんです
まあそこで自分が心清らかになったこと
真理わかったこと お釈迦様に報告しなくちゃいけないということに本人が決めて
これはブッダのおかげですから
これは報告して感謝しなくちゃいけないんだと
しかし すごい大勢の人々がいるところだからね
こんな人には前に行くことはできないんですね
いくらなんでも 例えばこちらに入ろうと思ったとして
ホームレスの人がいるとしましょう
こちらみんな集めてワイワイと祭りやってる時なんかは入らないでしょうね
もし入りたい入れたい気持ちがあっても
誰もいない時を見て 誰か一人ぐらいいる時はドアを開けている時はもうゆっくりこそっと来て
もうなんとか聞かなくちゃいけないでしょう
だからそういう立場で邪魔になったりはする
この人はお釈迦様に礼をしたいんですね
それで まあ遠く遠く まあ遠いところでじっと待っているんです
みんな出ていくまで みんな出てるところまで待っていて
もうみんな出て行っちゃった
それでまあ乞食の人でも今はもう誰もいないんだからね
なんとなく入れます それで入ろうとすると
何のことなく ある人が突然そちらに現れるんですね
ある日 その人にこの で
話すんです おい ちょっと待てなさいと
言って あなたはね 人間としてえらみじめで
かっこ悪くて 何もできんでしょうと
で あなたはもうこの乞食の中でも乞食扱いされるぐらい
もう人間の中でね 貧乏だと
すごい大変な人でしたからね
この人はいわゆる貧乏人のところに行っちゃうと
この人貧乏なんですね
本当に貧乏で人から乞食しているのに
その人お前みたいな貧乏と付き合いたくないんだよというぐらいものすごい貧乏
もう乞食したって何ももらえない
もう気持ち悪い人だから
そういうことを言って
しかし 私にはね すごい能力がありますよと
君をものすごい財産に恵まれるようにしてあげることできますと
1日にして億万長者にしてやるぞと
どうだい？まあ条件としてはそんな大したことはないんだと
あんたね ただこれだけ認めてくださいと
私はブッダのことは大嫌いやと
あの教えはまるっきり認めませんと
サンガのことも大嫌いやと
反対だと これだけサインしてくれと
まあ自分の国でも教会をそういうふうにサインを集めたりをします
それでお金くれるんです
それは仏教徒でいて それをやめて神様を信じることになりましたっていう
あの なんとかアフィデビッドと言いますけどね
それを書いてサインして証人の前へ出せば
まあお金くれると  私はもういわゆるもうブッダにもブッダの教えにも
その弟子たちにも大反対です
認めませんということだけ認めてくださいと
たったそれだけで あなたはたちまち億万長者にしてあげるぞ
したらこの乞食の人はこいつの顔を見て
あのね お前誰ですか？と
聞いたら  軽く見るなよと私を
私は神様の王様だよと
大作戦ですね あれは神々の王であるものやと
もうジジジ来ている間しゃべっているんですけど
神のところからそこら辺にいる悪霊でも話しちゃうと随分真面目に信じるでしょ
我々だったら 人間に神は話しかけてくれません
まして神の王様が で この場合は
この まあ神様の王様も自給自足
私はこういうものであると
それで普通は ははっ 参りましたということになるでしょうね
神様が来てブッダはもう認めませんとね
まあそれにも反抗してくれれば
それだけのお願いだから
別にどうったことないでしょう
それでこの乞食の人は
どう答えたかというと
この愚か者 お前みたいなくだらないけしからん奴は私と喋るなよと
この乞食が言うんです
何様のつもりだとお前はと
極限に無知で 愚か者で
根暗でとかね すごいもう非難的な根暗で
よく私と喋ろうと思ったことやと
神に対してそういうことを言うんです
あなたには神様の王様に言うんだ
あなたには私と喋る資格さえないんだよと
私は貧乏の中でも貧乏扱いされるされたと言ったでしょうに
お前のことでしょうと
私ほど豊かな人はいませんと
私は大金持ちで大平安安らぎを味わっています
それで自分が一番大金持ちということは
もう財産 7つですね 聖者の財産というのは七宝
私にこの七宝もありますよと
サッダーダナシーダダなんて信と戒律と懺悔
それからスッタですね
仏陀の教えを覚えていること
布施と智慧ですね その 7つ私にありますからね
何のことかと 貧乏はあんたのことじゃないかと
私の人生はだから無意味空しくはないんだよと
財産いっぱいありますということで
それでこの聖なる七宝ある人に対しては
少学者はあるいは独学者はね
貧乏だと言いませんよと
それでも帝釈天は結局はまあちょっと遊んだだけなんですけど
その人は仏陀を否定する人ではないんですけど
まあ試したかったんですね
何かいたずら好きですからね
まあしょうがないんですけど
で やられちゃったんですね
乞食の人に怒鳴られて
もうけなされちゃって
神様が人を から帰ってみようかなと思ったところで
クタクタやられちゃった
だからものすごいけなされたんですよ
ブッダは私には貧乏やと言いませんよと
私は一番金持ちやと言うんだよと
だから貧乏ってうまいでしょうと
それってのはすごい非難的な言葉なんですよ
私の生き方はブッダなら称賛
讃嘆するんだけど あんたでしょ
非難するのはと 言うと
相手が極端に無知ということになるんです
それで帝釈天がそれに別に怒ったわけでも
じゃあ天罰を与えるぞとか
そんな何のこともなく
ああそうかと言って そこでげじって
もうお釈迦様のところ先に行ったんです
その人来る前に まあ尊者今こういうことになりましたと
お釈迦様に報告するんですね
で お釈迦様は そうですね
あなたみたいなね 神々は 100人来てもね
1000人来ても  10万人来てもね
全部神々はもう もう全知全能の神やと言い張ってる人
何人来てもね ああいう人々の気持ち変えることはね
これは無理ですよと  そこでまた別なストーリーもありますけど
そこはカットしますけど
で  賢者と愚か者の差なんですね
だから世の中の考え方は完璧に否定されてます
世の中の人はそうやって神様が来て
この 3つの希望を叶ってくれる話だったらね
ありがたがりますね 汝の希望は 3つ叶えてあげるぞとか
でもそういうストーリーを書く人はもうみんな馬鹿にしてますよ
だからストーリー読んでみても
3つの希望を叶った話あるでしょうね
最後にはどうなったのかと
馬鹿を見ただけでしょうね
神様が来て 3つの希望を叶えてあげたのに
うまくいったわけじゃないでしょうね
あのドラえもんと同じなんですね
ドラえもんいろいろ道具を出しますけど
結局はもうろくなものでなくなっちゃうんですね
だからこの そういうふうにね
たまに輪廻転生のこのハリーポッターもそうでしょうしね
このドラえもんのエピソードでも
やっぱりどこかでなんとか馬鹿にしているんですね
だから一般人が愚か者はああいうふうに
もう何でもかんでも出してくる
どこでもドア出してくるならば
これはありがたいんですね
どこでもあるドアで出て行ったところでろくなことがないんですね
結局はあってもなくてもどうでもいいんじゃないかというね
現実に戻ってもらいたいんだけどね
そこまでは持っていっちゃうとストーリー成り立たない
そこまでは持っていかないんですね
ただもうひどい目に遭って
それで終わっちゃうんですね
ですから この世の中だったら
まあそういう気分でいるんだから
こちらでも同じ手段で
もう帝釈天がじきじき来て話すんだと
もう億万長者にしてやるぞと
たちまち それで逆にくたくたやられると
仏教の立場からは それが愚か者であって貧乏だと
私たちは貧乏じゃないんだよと
資産を持ってるんだよと
俗世間では道徳的にいることって面白くないんだと
それよりはもう金があればいいんじゃないかという考えちゃうんです
もう確信があっていいけど
何が別に確信が いわゆる信仰ですね
そんなのは気持ち悪いんだと
言いながら ものすごく気持ち悪い若い女の子たちの男たちの写真
ポスターばっかり部屋中飾っているんですね
時々若い人々はそういうタレントさんにももう線香まであげたりもするんです
本人の大事な本を潰してもあまり怒りません
そういう子供たちとは
例えば使ってるパソコンでも自分がいじったところで壊したっても
壊しちゃった 何とかするぞということで
でも貼ってるポスターに何かちょこっと何かやってみてください
殺されます だからこの
それはかっこよくて 大事に何か信じるというのは精神的なことに興味があるんだったら
あいつは変人だという風にするんですね
道徳を重んじる若者だったらもう変人で
それってのは普通の世間の常識なんですね
それで神様が願い事は三つ叶えてくれるならばね
これまたありがたい話で
という風に このこれは愚か者の思考で
財産というのは金じゃないんだよと
サッダーダナン シーラダナン
信と戒律 道徳あること
信仰と戒律 道徳あること
ヒリオッタッピヤンダナ
慚愧 悪いことを恐れる
悪いことを恥じる スッタダナン
よく学んでおく 本当のこと
俗世間のことを学んでも学んでも
全然もうどうにもならん
いくら俗世間の知識を学んで学んで
もう学術を完成しちゃって
もう技術を身につけちゃって
何かやったんだからといって何もやりなりませんからね
世の中はどうにもなりませんよ
何かやったらそれなりの付けがついてきます
付けって何？ そういうことになりますから
悪いことを恥じる 悪いことを怖がる
それもまた財産であると
なぜならば 悪いことを恥じる人
悪いことを怖がる人っていうのは悪いことをしないでしょうに
これで不幸にならないでしょう
だから一時的財産でも減る財産でもないんです
聖なる財産 宝物っていうのは増えるんであって
金で幸福になったならば金が減るんだから
それでその幸福も減るでしょうに
体も衰えちゃうんだから
それでもう意味がなくなっちゃうでしょうね
金持ちであっても 年を取ると同時に金との関係なくなっていくんですよ
自分ではケチで金が使わないで置いておいたったら金は減りませんよと思ったって
自分が年取るとその金との関係が減っていくんですよ
だってあっても使えないと状態になるんだから
それで死ぬ寸間で きちっと切っちゃうんです
関係なしと 他人のものであると
他人のものになる なれるものって何で自分のものやと思うんですかね
これは電車で もう座席空いてて座ったような感じでしょうね
座ったら自分の権利あるんだけど
だからって自分の座席じゃないでしょうに
誰も立ちなさいとは言いませんだけど
だからってこれは私の座席だとそちらで看板書いて
お墓まで作る いかに愚か者かと
もし自分が座ったところでちょこっと名前書いて立ったところで
もう乱暴な人やと もうもうもうおかしいんだと
常識知らないんだと 非難されるだけでしょう
公のみんなの財産壊す人やと
もしかするともうもう法律違反でも裁かれる可能性もあるでしょうに
なのに我々は平気でこれは私の土地
私のお金と ちゃんと看板つけてますからね
それって法律違反なんですよ
本当は 真理の法律違反なんです
宇宙の法則の で ここまで生きてきたんだよと永久的に土地を確保して
それこそお墓まで作るんだから
もう切りがないんです
お墓作っても誰も何とかしてくれませんから
何でしたっけ あれは この供養してくれませんから
それで永代供養はもうこれぐらいと言って
まあまあ一年一万ぐらいに計算して
それでお金取ったりバカにされてるだけ
やってませんよ あれは
昨日 昨日からね いくらでしたっけ？三十
三十三万円  三十三万 え？ 三十三年間
うん 一年一万ちょこっとでしょ
それなんてお寺でもなく
もうただのなんか会社でしょ
供養してくれると思う？でも値段が面白いんだからね
まあやるでしょうね みんなバカどもたちは
お寺でも永代供養に お布施取ってもやりません
その代わりに年一 年何回か
まあごく普通の法事やるだけで
まあそれはお寺ある限り一応やってますからね
自分がそれだと思っているならばいいんですけどね
でも お金あげる人はそうじゃなくて
わざとうちのナンダラカンダラさんのために
このお坊さんがもう供養してくれるだろうと
それはやりません  親戚が来たならば
自分の亡くなった方々のためにせっかく足運んできたならば
その場合はもう真剣に
もうわけのわからないお経であっても真剣にやってあげますけどね
おそらくインターネットでも永代供養のお金し
お金払うことはできると思いますよ
今は そうするとお寺に行くこともいらないだからね
会社に行くことも要りません
人間どこまで愚かっていうね
まぁとにかく私はこの財産
本当の財産は何なのかという説明なんですけど
この土地とこの銀行口座
私のものだと思っていても
使えばなくなるし 使わなくても自分が日々年取っていくんだから
権利が減って減っていくんですね
減っていって 息が止めた瞬間で終わりと
あなたのものじゃありませんと
だったら我々は電車の座席に座ったら
座席をいじらないで 丁寧に使って
次の人にも気持ちよく使えるようにという生き方でしょ
道徳的な生き方っていうのは
足を広げないで 足を揃って座って
手がドカーンと広げないで
立つ時でも隣の人の体にぶつからないように丁寧に立って電車から降りるでしょうに
なんでそういう生き方しないんですかね
それが電車に対する正しい使用方法でしょうに
それでたまたま自分がちょこっと棚の上にあったものを取ろうと思ったり
あるいはカバンのもの何か取ろうとしたことが
やっぱり立っていかないと取れない場合は立って
あ で 取ろうしている間に誰かが座っていたならば
これは私が座っていたと言わないでしょうね
私が座っているところ立ちなさい
その場合 その場合は違法かもしれません
違法じゃないんだけど
ちょっと行儀が悪いかもしれませんだけど
取られちゃった まあしょうがないということでしょうね
しかし その人はまあそれはまあいいや
もう取られたんだからね
立ったんだからねということでれば人ができてあって
なんて悪い連中だな この世の中何て汚いことでしょうかね
なんでもう私の座っていたところにちょっと腰を上げただけで
パクッとそちらに食いかかって取るんです
なんて行儀悪いでしょう
頭の中でゴチャゴチャ思っていると性格悪い
でも実際そういうことをやってるんじゃないんだよ
我々世の中で ちょっと誰かに何か言われただけで
誰かちょこっと商売で自分がちょっと損しただけで
ずーっと怒り苦しんで悩んでるでしょうね
初めから自分のものじゃないんだから
これ誰かに不正的に不法もうもうで
不正的に取られたって
まあいいや 取られたものだからと
だから生きる哲学は ただ電車見てもわかるはずなんですけど
わからないでしょうね
頭がいいんだからね そういうすごいことを考えてるんだから
こういう単純具体的なシンプルなことは考えません
電車の正しい使い方で人生の生き方があるんです
看板書いて置くんじゃない
私の指定席ということはね
ありえない たとえ指定席を取っても
その電車 1本に限るですからね
乗り遅れたら乗れるんだけど
指定席はなしと だからまあ本当の財産っていうのはそんなもんじゃなくて
まあ悪を恥じる 悪を怖がる
そうすると幸福になる
それがあれば減る財産じゃないんですね
増える財産なんですね
ブッダの教えを理解しておく
チャーガ ものを与えることはことに慣れる
で 智慧を開発する その 7つですよ
ということで 無知な人は自分を自分の敵のごとく行動する
悪 悪行為だけ喜んでやっているんだという
お釈迦様の言葉の意味はそういう意味なんです
じゃあ 話は終了です  [背景音]